the european union is home to around
6 of the world's population
that carries a disproportionate burden
of one disease
cancer one in two
eu citizens are estimated to develop
cancer
which kills more europeans under 65 than
any other disease
and with costs of cancer healthcare
rising to around 100 billion
euros in europe each year
enough is enough it's time to act
this battle is being fought on multiple
fronts and there is plenty the eu can do
decisions in many areas like health
policy
environment and agriculture impact
cancer numbers and survival rates
for example healthy eating and lifestyle
could prevent over 40 percent of cancers
and help those who already have cancer
to have the greatest impact the
different measures should work together
the knowledge center on cancer will make
it possible to coordinate eu
scientific and technical actions to beat
the disease
we will provide reliable scientific and
technical information for prevention
detection and treatment policies
manage and expand the european cancer
information system
which tracks cancer trends develop
and provide guidelines and quality
assurance schemes
for screening diagnosis and care and act
as an
honest data broker connecting with the
european health data space
the eu's in-house cancer experts and
policy analysts will manage the
knowledge center
driving forward europe's new
health-focused
beating cancer plan and the
research-focused horizon
europe cancer mission
together we can build a stronger
european health union
find out more about the knowledge center
and eu actions on cancer
[Music]